ils n'ont pas changé à part peut-être
une moustache ou de josiane balasko
marie-anne chazel et chaises blanches
qui sont là des géants jugnot thiais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bakou
à c
on se retrouve ensemble moi ya des gens
que j'ai pondu pilotes dont j'ai à peine
retenu
donc maintenant on attend les
enseignants d'anglais tonnes de boue
merci d'un débat n'y a pas grand monde
dans la salle mais là quand même ça on
est content on y aurait on envie d
connaissent extrêmement fort et
intelligent
monsieur blanc ah oui je voulais donc
c'est toi qui voulais jaser oui je
voulais jaser je voulais faire un album
je voulais démontrer leader parce que je
suis pas en condition physique pour le
faire avec ma camarade de marina qui en
présentant la la bande annonce des césar
a attaqué la couche d'ozone et je ne
pourrai pas le faire moi même je suis
pas en état d'esprit j'avais pris une
application mais j'ai peur que ça merde
enfin son jeu mauvais alors c'est un
truc de paix tout bête parce que ça fait
toujours rire avec des années et je sais
pas si ça va un peu plus élégant
je suis touché jeudi et enfin une fois
oui parce que d'habitude elle le fait en
présentiel comme on dit parce que il n'y
avait pas les applications tout ça on
était jeunes et moi ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir ce évidemment que je
mets
donc ce césar me fait tellement plaisir
parce qu'il en fait me ramène à d'abord
mes camarades que l'on n'a pas été
ensemble depuis très longtemps ou sur la
même scène
et puis aussi parce que ça m'a ça m'a
rappelé des souvenirs
pourquoi tu te tournent vers moi parce
que je me rappelle le nom mais pas du
tout je voulais voilà faut que vous
compreniez l'ambiance qui régnait on
jouait donc ce qui est devenu les
bronzés c'était amour coquillages et
crustacés jeu jouer le même rôle que
dans le film c'est là j'étais souvent en
maillot de bain en slip main sur scène
et que josy avait profité d'un moment où
j'étais absente pour innover mon slip de
bain de d'extrait de violette de tous et
on explique qu'il est mais j'en change
est tous les deux jours mais j'étais du
yaourt de sud
c'est comme du comique bbc épouvantable
assez pour pouvoir asseoir donné ça peut
durer des plans très courts c'est-à-dire
j'ai passé tous et c'est toute la soirée
évidemment les spectateurs étaient ceux
demandés de sa mère et ensuite on est
allé dîner au restaurant et j'ai bien vu
que les tables se vidait autour de nous
parce que je dégageais la même odeur de
violette de toulouse donc je la remercie
ce soit merci mais ça ne me fait pas
mais ça n'est fait est-ce pour les peaux
maintenant l'aimable anodine et ça y est
c'est bondé mozilla temps avait passé
son attention parce qu'elles soient
réunies juste pour vous dire qu on est
très heureux d'être là ça nous a fait
vraiment une super belle surprise de
voir debout doucement doucement tir et
ça me fait ch a dit surpris de vous voir
debout
je vous remercie particulier parce que
doucement thierry ça m'est arrivé
rarement d'être là donc ça me touche
d'autant plus et je remercie évidemment
l'académie pour ce très joli prix de ces
les césar les 20 40 6e césar merci les
46e de son jumeau en plus c'est bien on
vous dira que bon ce prix récompense
certainement cette magnifique que
longévité vous avez vu les bestiaux là
ils sont pas même pas mal pour l'heure h
et puis aussi peut être les relais du
costume que porte monsieur lhermitte qui
a exactement 40 ans cela mais ça y est
doucement tirer et qu'est ce que je vous
dis bien d'autrui et aussi est aussi
peut-être parce que le public que nous
prouve son amour depuis quelques
semaines quelques mois quelques années
donc ça ça me fait très plaisir mais moi
y'a juste une chose que je veux dire
qu'il sera reliée à ce très très bel
objet ce sujet c'est qu'en fait tout ça
c'est arrivé parce qu'il ya eu deux
choses majeures dans notre vie en dehors
de notre jeunesse de l'époque c'était
qu'on s'aimait et c'est qu'on riait
ensemble et c'est ça la clé de ce qui
s'est passé après vaud l'ain
[Applaudissements]
ne croyez pas que je j'ai un problème
c'est juste que je j'utilise quelque
chose que dans vous n'entendrez pas
parler dans les médias mainstream
mystream je sais pas comment on prononce
mainstream et qui est financée par les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
parce que c'est la méthode du professeur
peroni que j'utilise évidemment on se
garde bien d'en parler qu'il a découvert
que si on appuyer très fort sur les deux
pouces avec le majeur et l'index ont
déclenché le méridien du nez et si on
faisait beaucoup de pression dans les
fosses nasales et les fausses gorges x
qu'on a pris le virus étaient détruits
et donc je vous encourage tous à le
faire payer tout ou partie merci donc je
voudrais dire merci aux spectateurs et
aux peuples et la peyronie je pense
qu'il y aura trois adresses qui arrivera
les sept nains là les suivants voilà moi
je suis heureusement nous ne sommes pas
25 très émues d'être là parce que c'est
vrai que on a pas l'habitude je les ai
la dernière fois c'était quand on est
venu il ya quoi il ya 40 ans on n'a pas
beaucoup bougé
on est à peu près les mêmes je n'en sais
rien fait et ses muscles et oui on s'est
musclé on sait aussi vrai c'est vrai
qu'on s'est musclé alors voilà je
voulais aussi remercier de évidemment
l'académie qui nous fait cet honneur
bon c'est quand même débrouillé sur
l'année où il ya personne
merci merci à l'académie au nom j'en
profite pour dire quand même que la
façon du costume de thierry ça rend
hommage à notre pays parce que c'est une
façon qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui à
des tissus sa 45 ans la navette
on sait que les enfants font des shorts
avec et arriveront en profiter c'est
magnifique
c'était ça aussi la france
non c'est pas un discours ce sont mes
jeux mes tests mais si j'ai mon
justificatif de noms je vais juste dire
un petit mot
d'ordinaire il ya un léger faux c voire
à gouffre n'est ce pas même qui sépare
les les clowns qui remettent les césars
d'habitude et les artistes sérieux qui
les reçoivent et bien ce soir l'académie
jette une passerelle n'est ce pas
provisoire sur ce gouffre que nous
empruntons joyeusement à ses bordereaux
merci et bonne et je remercie je voulais
aussi remercié la chance le destin oui
dieu peut-être de nous avoir réunis
d'avoir rencontré ces crétins parce que
quand même je m'aperçois que nous sommes
depuis plus de 50 ans qu'un contact
[Applaudissements]
tous mes camarades je vais vous dire
merci merci à l'académie des césars mais
rooney au public merci à tout le monde
et au peuple
oui au peuple mais je vais être honnête
avec vous je suis un peu déçu parce que
quand on m'a dit tu vas voir un césar je
pensais avoir le meilleur espoir
masculin
ça fait 40 ans que je l'attends à 6 mais
un jour je l'aurai sous l'oreille ne
lâche pas merci merci beaucoup merci d
merci à chacun de vos autres chacun à
vôtre et vous échangez paris 8e
voilà merci merci beaucoup bravo